hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime out pro and today i will be taking
you on yet another
wild ride on the emotional roller
coaster that is the boku no hero manga
right now deck who finally broke down
completely bakugou finally apologized to
deku for everything
ochako finally held deku's hand
how scandalous let's talk about it if
you enjoyed the boku no hero content
here on the channel and you want us to
keep it going you know what to do just
leave a quick
like and comment and of course if you're
new to the channel or you just haven't
subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications now a quick thank you
to
afk arena for sponsoring this video
afk arena is a fun light rpg with
hundreds of fantasy heroes
split between seven unique factions each
hero has his own lore and background
they are all beautifully designed in the
renaissance art style
and thanks to afk arena's generous bonus
system you will be able to collect and
build your epic dream heroes without
having to grind
all day long and now here's the big news
afk arena is updating their new summer
mode on august 3rd
and they are introducing massive new
features
including new game modes along with
clearing stages and defeating your
enemies you will now be able to obtain
additional bonuses through fishing
farming and ship repair these more
casual modes will allow you to earn
awesome bonuses while taking it easy and
relaxing over the summer
the new update will also give you one
free celestial or hypogen's hero
60 free summons and other amazing extras
but this is a limited time offer the new
gameplay and bonuses will only be
available for two weeks between august
3rd
and august 17th so don't miss it
download afk arena right now
link in the description finally this
video will of course contain boku no
hero manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution
you have been warned first up i want to
address the big minita controversy from
the previous chapter that was actually
trending on twitter for several days
in case you guys didn't know many people
on twitter were speculating that mineta
might be attracted to deku based on what
he said to deku in chapter 321
because i initially read the unofficial
translation of that chapter
this didn't even cross my mind the
unofficial translation didn't have
anything out of the ordinary however
when the official translation came out
on viz.com
it had minita saying the following words
to deku i never thought it was your
power that made you
awesome i fell for you when you were
scared and sweating buckets and quaking
in your boots
back when we found a path forward
together the way you were
back then that part where minata said i
fell for you
immediately blew up on twitter with some
people claiming that minata just
revealed that he loves
deku but soon after that several people
who are fluent in japanese pointed out
that while the original japanese
expression used here
is generally used for expressing
romantic interest
it can also be used to express platonic
affection but in like a dramatic way
so if i understand it correctly it's
kind of like minita saying to deku
i freaking love you bro that appears to
be how the japanese manga readers took
it because
apparently in japan there was no
confusion about
this exchange between minitan deku
audrey from aitaiki mochi has a great
thread on twitter clarifying this so
definitely follow her
if you have twitter she tweets a ton of
breaking news and updates about mha
straight from japan so it's a great
account to follow
from the context of the chapter and from
what we know about minata i believe that
miita was just being dramatic and that
he was not expressing romantic feelings
for deku
pretty much all the class 1a students
have been expressing their admiration
for deku
in these last few chapters in one way or
another so it makes sense that mineta
would do the same
so yeah unless horikoshi says otherwise
i think this was probably just a
platonic i love you bro
type deal at the same time people have
the right to ship whomever they want
these are just fictional characters so
who cares
but i did want to take some time to talk
about this because i want to use this
opportunity to urge everyone not to feed
into twitter toxicity on this topic
or other similar topics unfortunately no
matter what horikoshi does now he is
going to be attacked by some segment of
the fandom
if he comes out and says that minata
loves deku as a friend
someone's going to be upset if he comes
out and says that mina loves deck was
more than a friend
other people are going to be upset and
frankly even if he doesn't say anything
someone will probably be upset as i said
you can
ship whomever you want but please don't
try to force your personal ship on
everyone else
and definitely don't attack the author
of the story if your preferred ship
doesn't become canon
i'm not saying that you guys who watch
my videos are the type of people who
engage
in this toxic stuff in fact i'm certain
that the vast majority of you would
never do that
but unfortunately we've already had too
many instances of horikoshi and
other mangaka getting threatening
messages from keyboard commandos on
twitter
over shipping and other nonsense and i
just want to take this opportunity to
say that i have no sympathy for that
type of behavior
okay now let's get back to the action
the latest chapter which is named after
bakugou
starts off with deku anita dropping back
down to the ground
after ochako releases the effect of her
zero gravity quirk
before decuanida hit the ground
kirishima shows up and he is able to
grab them
kirishima then goes on to also express
his admiration for deku
just like the rest of the class has been
doing hirishima remembers hearing an
old news story about a kid his age who
bravely rushed in to save his friend
from a villain
and kirishima knows that this kid was
deku kirishima says that being a hero
has nothing to do with being strong or
being
special it's all about that type of
heroic attitude which drove a young
deku to risk his own life to save his
friend
after kirishima says this the rest of
class 1a converges on the spot where he
deku anida are standing mina also calls
out to deku
and asks him to come back to them so
that they can all return to ua
together but deku is still being
stubborn
he says that he would love to go back
but it's just too dangerous
there are too many people seeking
shelter at the ua right now
and he doesn't want to make them a
target for the villains
that is when bakugou himself steps in
bakugo says that back when they were
kids he had always looked down on deku
because
deku was quirkless in some ways deku was
way behind
bakugo mainly in terms of strength and
power since bakugo had a great
flashy quirk and deku had nothing but
in other ways bakugou actually felt that
deku was
always far ahead of him i assume that
bakugo is referring to deku's kindness
and compassion
and his courage and strength of
character even in the face of being
quirkless
it was easy for bakugo to be popular
confident and brave when he was born
with an incredibly strong
quirk but the fact that deku had such
inner courage
strength and resolve despite being born
quirkless
was something that bakugou couldn't
relate to and so bakugou was clearly
self-conscious
about this fact bakugou didn't want to
admit to himself that deep down he
actually felt inferior to deku
and so he compensated by belittling deku
and putting him down
bakugo knows that the way he treated
deku had nothing to do with
deku himself bakugo acted that way
because he himself was insecure
and he couldn't stand the fact that a
quirkless kid was in some ways
superior to him bakugou then proceeds to
finally fully apologize to deku for
everything that he had done to him
in the past bakugou proclaims that deku
has been faithful to the ideals of
all might and that he acted like a true
hero up to this point
as we know this is extremely high praise
from someone like bakugo since bakugo
also deeply respects and idolizes all
might
it's also funny to see bakugo
apologizing like this when in the anime
he's still being a jerk most of the time
but this moment has been a long time
coming so i'm very happy that this
finally happened bakugou really did
mistreat deku for many years
and although he has definitely developed
a lot since then
this public apology to deku is the
culmination of bakugo's progression from
an insecure bully to a true hero
and a true friend after apologizing to
deku in front of everyone
bakugo goes on to say that deku's heroic
ideals can only take him
so far he has reached his limit he can
barely stand
on his own and now is the time for deku
to
trust his friends sure all might like to
do everything on his own
and that is what deku has been doing up
to this point but in order to actually
surpass
all might deku has to accept that the
most effective way to protect the ua
from the villains is for everyone to
work together
and this is such an interesting moment
since deku finally realizes that he is
ahead of his classmates in terms of
physical strength
but they are ahead of him in terms of
emotional strength
and so as he collapses to the ground
deku apologizes to his classmates for
saying that they can't keep up with him
bakugou then grabs deku before deku hits
the ground
and all of class 1a is clearly affected
by this
emotionally although they're definitely
not crying or anything it's just like
rain on their face okay guys it's just
rain ochako seems to be especially moved
by this situation as we might have
expected
but she doesn't approach deku again she
decides to give him his space for now
and then the class discusses their next
steps
momo says that finding deku was only the
first hurdle that they had to clear
but things will get more difficult from
now on
deku then passes out and when he wakes
up again he seems to be
at the entrance of the ua compound where
a massive wall now protects the school
grounds from the outside world
deku then sees space hero 13
with her mask off that's right we
finally got a space hero 13
face reveal and i have to admit that she
is pretty cute
i remember back in the day there was all
this speculation about whether 13 was
male
female or whether she even had a gender
but then later it was confirmed that 13
was indeed a girl
and it is extremely cool to finally see
what she looks like
13 explains that most civilians are now
located in shelters like the one within
the grounds of ua
and the people who are still outside are
mostly villains prison skps
various vigilante groups and militant
extremists
deku learns that all the work that he
did in fighting the villains on his own
definitely helped
the heroes and the police and even
though this is still a difficult
situation for everyone
everyone is doing their best to make
things better
nevertheless the situation within the ua
is not as peaceful as we might have
expected
in fact hundreds of people have gathered
at the entrance to the compound and they
are protesting against
letting deku inside the ua grounds these
people are afraid that if deku is let in
they will all become targets for
shigaraki and the other villains
that is kind of messed up when you
consider how hard deku has worked to
protect
these very people from the villains but
i guess that's human nature
when people are scared they tend to
become paranoid ungrateful and sometimes
downright cruel
and that's exactly what's happening here
deku is obviously affected by the words
of these protesters since he's been
trying to avoid making them a target
this entire time so for deku this is
like his worst
fears are coming true everything he was
trying to avoid
has come to pass he is about to walk
away without a word
but that is the moment in which ochako
decides to
make her move she grabs deku's hand
and tells him not to worry about it damn
ochako hao lewd
anyway she goes on to say that ida
bakugo and everyone else
worked hard to get deku back and they
will not
let him go again after all they can't
afford to let him go
if they do who will save the heroes when
they
are in trouble and that is how this
emotional tear-jerking chapter ends
with ochako ready to face the protesters
alongside deku
and everyone else in class 1a presumably
getting ready to back them up
as well this is quite the dilemma with
all of these people
protesting against deku's presence but
after everything that they've been
through to get deku back
there is no way in hell that they will
give deku up to that mob
and while i'm sure the deku feels bad
about this unexpected welcome party i
think that he has now
finally learned that he can't do
everything alone
all might tried to do everything on his
own and while he was an amazing hero
he was not the perfect hero if deku
wants to surpass
his mentor he has to learn from his
mistakes and he has to trust his friends
and comrades honestly this chapter had a
lot of great moments
and this is one to remember i loved
seeing bakugo finally owning up to his
mistakes and apologizing in front of
everyone
the old cocky and obnoxious bakugou
would never have done that
especially not in public in front of all
of these people
bakugou has matured a lot and i
definitely respect that
i also love that random space hero 13
face reveal
it did not disappoint finally i really
appreciated how ochako stepped up at the
end of the chapter
first she sensed that deku was
overwhelmed so she gave him his space
but then when deku needed her the most
she
grabbed his hand and stood by his side
pretty freaking adorable is ochako about
to summon the courage to confess her
feelings to deku
at some point in the near future i do
like them as a couple
and the story has definitely been
hinting at a potential romance between
them for a long time
so i'm definitely rooting for them let
me know what you guys thought of this
historic chapter
down in the comments below which was
your favorite part and what do you think
is going to happen
next if you enjoyed this pokuno hero
video and you want to see more in the
future just leave a quick like it only
takes a second but it helps a lot
and if you're new to anime pro or maybe
watch our videos but you haven't taken
the time to subscribe yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting the bell and then selecting that
option that says all
if you don't do that you're still gonna
miss a ton of our videos even if you are
subscribed it's just how youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
animeopror thanks again to our sponsor
afk arena check them out
link in the description as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you